how can you be
Unapologetic and
non-negotiable see so many of you want
to play Big in the world but you keep
making it optional and every time it
gets too hard you sit it back down the
moment you make it non-negotiable not an
option slide every option off the table
you're not wondering about the mountain
and how big it is because you said you
must bow
down you have to have a level of
certainty for you you got believe in you
bank on you trust in you like you never
have before in every single thing that
you've ever done every single thought
you've ever had every single decision
you ever made built you for such a time
as this and you are perfect for the job
yes